dans l'actualité ce soir deux étudiants
français ont été tués à londres c'était
dimanche mais on vient seulement de
l'apprendre
nous retrouvons maryse burgot en direct
dans un instant patrick de carolis sort
de sa réserve pour la première fois le
président de france télévisions marc
publiquement son désaccord avec la
réforme en cours
annoncé par nicolas sarkozy il n'exclut
pas de démissionner un nouveau fichier
controversé pour la police les mineurs
pourront être recensées dès l'âge de 13
ans en cas de menace à l'ordre public
yves critiques des magistrats et des
éducateurs un attentat d'un nouveau
genre à jerusalem un palestinien au
volant d'une pelleteuse a foncé dans la
foule il y a trois morts plus le
conducteur et une quarantaine de blessés
le conseil national du parti socialiste
s'est ouvert ce soir 21h contributions
sont déposées en vue du congrès quelles
différences quelles orientations au delà
des querelles de personnes on
s'intéressera à ce soir au débat d idées
enfin le tennis à wimbledon arnaud
clément va batailler ce soir si le temps
le permet pour une place en demi finale
rodger federer est déjà qualifié bonsoir
et bienvenue à tous d'abord donc cette
information france 2 deux étudiants
français ont été tués dimanche dernier à
londres à leur domicile
deux jeunes de 23 ans originaire de
clermont-ferrand bonsoir maryse burgot
vous avez d'autres informations
oui ces deux meurtres sont confirmés ce
soir par scotland yard la police
britannique qui devrait donner demain
matin à 10h une conférence de presse à
ce sujet les deux corps sans vie de ces
deux étudiants ont été retrouvés dans un
appartement dans un quartier populaire
du sud est de londres selon la police
britannique après ces deux meurtres qui
auraient été commis au couteau le feu a
été mis à l'appartement
bien sûr ce soir les parents de ses deux
ressortissants français
deux étudiants qui viennent de clermont
ferrand ses parents sont à londres ils
sont aidés suivi par les services du
consulat français et demain matin la
police britannique devrait lancer un
appel à témoins pour tenter de
comprendre les circonstances de ce
double
meurtre commis sur des ressortissants je
pensais au coeur de la capitale
britannique
merci maryse on y revient d'ici à la fin
de ce journal en cas de nouvelles
informations
en france la querelle sur la réforme de
la télévision publique a donc pris un
nouveau tour aujourd'hui depuis des mois
patrick de carolis s'était montré
conciliant
ce matin il est monté au créneau comme
on dit sur le financement sur les
critiques aussi adressé par nicolas
sarkozy il a fait connaître son
désaccord
daniel wolfromm marque de langenhagen
l'histoire commence pour le président
sarkozy est accueilli fraîchement par
une partie du personnel de france
télévisions
agacé tendu il réitère alors sur france
3 ses critiques contre les programmes du
service public
pour tout dire je trouve que les
programmes de france télévision pro
semble encore trop aux programmes d'une
chaîne privée qui vous quelle est la
qualité c'est pas vous qui allez les
inquiétudes des journalistes tension et
réplique ce matin de patrick de carolis
17h49 jean michel aphatie votre invité
le président de france télévision je
trouve que lorsqu'on dit qu'il n'ya pas
de différence entre la télévision de
service public ou les télévisions
privées je trouve cela faux
je trouve cela stupide et je trouve cela
injuste profondément injuste peu après
bien la sortie du conseil des ministres
et cette réaction du ministre de la
culture je trouve que c'est pas normal
il ya certains mots j'espère que je
pense qu'ils ont dépassé sa pensée c'est
pas normal de prononcer certains
objectifs comme supplie de vote ça c'est
pas possible
mais en toile de fond il y à toute la
question du financement du service
public
autre mise au point de patrick de
carolis j'estime aujourd'hui que nous
n'avons pas les moyens de nos ambitions
futures
donc nous allons faire ce plan
d'affaires je vais y mettre toute mon
énergie tout mon professionnalisme
nous allons travailler avec les services
de l'état que je respecte
ils sont compétents et puis à la fin
d'été
courant septembre nous verrons si le
conti yesil continuer je m'en
féliciterais je le dirai s'ils n'y est
pas je prendrai
responsabilité moi je lui dis simplement
que l'heure des comptes n'a pas sonné et
que on vérifiera s'il compte est bon au
moment où il aura engagé le travail sur
le contenu parce que ce qui intéresse
les français c'est le travail sur le
contenu je crois qu'il est temps de s'y
mettre avec ses équipes et celles voix
sur l'audiovisuel doit être rédigé cet
été par les services du gouvernement
pour être présenté au parlement dès cet
automne attention donc dans
l'audiovisuel public et malaise aussi
dans l'armée la démission hier du
général cuche qui avait été tancée par
nicolas sarkozy après laffaire de
carcassonne prend une dimension
politique certains parlent de crise de
confiance dans une institution déjà
ébranlée par les coupes budgétaires
shera griesbeck christophe kenck le
public l'avait découvert en 99 lorsqu'il
commandait les troupes françaises au
kosovo depuis hier il revient sur le
devant de la scène la démission du
général cuche est devenu une affaire
cuche et sa mise au point du mal à
convaincre
cette démission était exclusivement lié
au drame survenu dimanche à carcassonne
déclare le général dans un communiqué un
patron de l'armée de terre qui
démissionne à la suite d'un fait divers
certes au graff 17 blessés c'est sans
précédent depuis hier il a droit aux
hommages de circonstances mais rien de
la part du président de la république
il ya d'abord eu ses mots de nicolas
sarkozy chef des armées lundi matin à
carcassonne c'est toute la chaîne qui
devra s'expliquer la personne qui a fait
ça
et l'encadrement l'encadrement le mot
est lâché devant témoins nicolas sarkozy
aurait même invectivé le général vous
êtes des amateurs lui aurait-il dit vous
n'êtes pas des professionnels
un propos brutale dénoncé aujourd'hui
par l'opposition
je crois que le président sarkozy ferait
bien d'être prudent et pas de se payer
des extras meurt la démission du général
cuche intervient quinze jours après la
présentation du livre blanc de la
défense par le président de la
république ça s'est pas bien passé pour
faire court je dire que dans la même
salle
il a émis des militaires des policiers
des préfets et c'est donc en fait si mal
aux militaires affrétés par le militaire
fait le pas qui parle à la fonction
publique
quand des militaires ont reçu le message
du président leur public façon
extrêmement négative en disant bea qui
parle-t-il l'armée de terre découvre
alors qu'elle va perdre 10 7% de ses
effectifs déjà dans une lettre au chef
d'état major le général cuche avait
parlé de risque de paupérisation et sous
couvert d'anonymat dégradées avait
dénoncé le plan de réforme
'l'annonce des fermetures de casernes a
été une fois de plus reportée signe que
la grande muette est vraiment en crise
alors audiovisuel armée deux
institutions et 2 cris sur fond
d'incompréhension avec l'elysée bonsoir
michaël darmon vous êtes précisément à
l'elysée ce sont deux nouveaux fronts
pour nicolas sarkozy
oui david on a vraiment l'impression
d'assister à un raidissement en fait de
certains corps de la société face à la
pratique et le style direct de nicolas
sarkozy d'ailleurs le chef de l'état cet
après midi a réuni son son g7 son club
des sept ministres pour caler les
argumentaires où on a reconnu au sein de
cette réunion que cela tangue et en ce
moment sur fond de sondages qui baisse
et d'ailleurs d'économie aux
perspectives peu favorables alors on a
l'habitude de voir nicolas sarkozy créer
la diversion lancer les débats de
société à partir de faits d'événements
importants pour un peu finalement changé
et occuper le terrain mais cette fois
c'est diversion et bien ce deviennent
des crises elle même on a l'impression
que la rupture sarkozienne qui est en
train de s'incarner et bien génèrent des
réactions d'un style inédit alors à
l'elysée on affirme on martèle kid le
choix étrange entre l'immobilisme la
réforme et que nicolas sarkozy est dans
son rôle mais on le voit la rupture
sarkozienne installe
un dialogue d'un genre pour le moins
musclée et nouveau entre la société et
le nicolas sarkozy le chef de l'état
michaël darmon en direct de l'elysée
merci michael et c'est le général
irastorza qui a été nommé aujourd'hui
chef d'état major de l'armée de terre en
remplacement de bruno cuche il a 55 ans
il en effet jusque là le numéro deux il
a un joli nom mais il provoque des
remous la police va bientôt disposer
d'un nouveau fichier appelé edwige signe
particulier les mineurs pourront être
recensées dès l'âge de 13 ans lorsqu'ils
sont susceptibles de porter atteinte à
l'ordre public c'est la formule employée
on va s'y arrêter un instant d'abord de
quoi s'agit-il
explication sophie rodier mathias second
des vitrines brisées des magasins pillés
c'était il ya quinze jours rue du
commerce à paris qu à l'issue d'une
réunion de lycéens qui fêtaient la fin
du bac
un groupe de jeunes mineurs à tout
casser sur son passage pour identifier
ces bandes organisées d'adolescents de
plus en plus jeunes les policiers
disposeront désormais d'un fichier
baptisé edwige la fichier qui a pour but
de surveiller et de prévenir des actes
futurs de délinquance et notamment de
répertorier des gens qui sont
potentiellement susceptibles de troubler
l'ordre public
tout mineur à partir de 13 ans
susceptibles de troubler l'ordre public
peut être enregistrée dans ce fichier
état civil numéros de téléphone adresses
emails antécédents judiciaires mêmes
signes particuliers photographie et
comportements toutes ces informations
seront consignés pour une durée
indéterminée
même si le mineur fiche et n'a pas
commis d'infraction un fichier
équivalent était déjà tenus par les
renseignements généraux
mais ils concernaient uniquement les
plus de 18 ans son élargissement est
déjà critiqué la commission nationale
informatique et libertés demande qu'il
ne s'applique qu'aux mineurs de plus de
16 ans alors ce fichier est il utile il
risque
y at il un risque de dérive nous y
reviendrons dans un instant pour des
raisons techniques nous ne sommes pas en
mesure pour l'instant de vous
présenté ce sujet débat sur ce nouveau
fichier edvige
en attendant des images de cette
nouvelle collision entre un train et un
camion à une intersection de voies
ferrées il s'agit d'un convoi de
marchandises et l'accident a eu lieu sur
une route privée dans une zone
industrielle près de dijon le chauffeur
resté coincé dans son poids lourds a été
grièvement blessé noter par ailleurs
qu'un mois après le drame d'allinges où
sept collégiens avaient été tués à un
passage à niveau
le chauffeur a été remise en liberté
vous le savez il est soupçonné d'être
passé au feu rouge ce qu'il a démenti
l'économie coup de frein sur les prix
coup de froid sur les ventes le
retournement du marché immobilier se
confirme le nombre de transactions a
chuté de près de 10% en ile-de-france
selon les derniers indices caroline
thébaux mathieu renier ce 60 m²
intéresse particulièrement cet acheteur
et pour cause
monsieur ne sera plus qu'à 5 km de paris
lui qui depuis 25 ans habite à 40 km de
là prix 325 1000 euros avec un point
fort important économies envisagées
santoro par mois
c'est en tout cas ce qu'ils dépensent
aujourd'hui à la pompe vous prenez la
voiture on m'avait sur paris nice etc
nous aurons comptant les amendes les
sens enfin maintenant naissance j'aurais
jamais imaginé en partant à la retraite
que le pétrole aurait fait ça un budget
sens en hausse des taux d'intérêt élevés
autant de facteurs qui dissuade les
acheteurs cet agent immobilier constate
aussi que les banques sont de plus en
plus frileuse on a eu dernièrement
d'ailleurs pas plus tard qu'il ya 48
heures un refus de prêt pour
pour la vente d'une maison c'est la
première fois en quatre ans bilan des
ventes qui chute en france 15% en moins
prévus en 2008 pour l'ancien est déjà
moins 20% de mises en chantier pour le
neuf
ces trois derniers mois mais il ya
toujours des disparités de prix exemple
en ile de france
la petite couronne voit ses tarifs
baisser de 0,3 pour cent la grande
stagne à 0 7%
mais paris vous êtes encore ses prix
augmenter de 1,1 pour cent sur paris
comme sur les grandes villes de province
resteront ils verraient seront chères
car c'est la loi de l'offre et de la
demande il n'y a pas suffisamment de
logements pour beaucoup de demande donc
une pression sur les prix et les prix
sont orientés encore à la hausse malgré
tout le nombre total d'agencés
immobilières baisse un signe du
retournement du marché
après dix années de hausse toujours à
propos d'immobilier le dernier bilan
maintenant de la loi sru il vient d'être
rendu public
vous le savez les communes sont tenues
de rattraper leur retard pour disposer
de 20 % de logements sociaux
et bien c'est plutôt une bonne surprise
400 municipalités sur 730 ont respecté
leur engagement voici deux exemples un
bon et un mauvais élève entre guillemets
reportage perrine bonnet alain location
du calme des espaces verts une petite
piscine
contrairement aux apparences nous sommes
bien dans du logement social le
voisinage il est très sympathique et on
a vraiment une qualité de vie
extraordinaire on y habitaient les hlm 1
j'ai rien à voir ça l avoir j'ai hâte à
personne que bute au dessus du toit d'un
jardin cette résidence est le tout
dernier programme d'habitat social de
cannes du hlm à taille humaine que la
ville a choisi de développer pour
attirer de jeunes actifs avec 300
nouvelles offres de logements par an
cannes fait partie des bons élèves
recensés par le ministère comme
marseille toulouse saint cloud marcq en
baroeul où lyon par exemple
d'autres par contre sont pointés du
doigt comme le chesnay dans les yvelines
diaries marignane fréjus nice neuilly
sur seine où la petite commune de
lézignan
en seine et marne ici il ya moins de 9%
d'habitat social alors que la loi en
impose 20% mais le maire a une
explication ces dernières années selon
lui tous les programmes de logements
sont attaqués en justice par un
collectif d'habitants
l'association une association qui veut
que rien ne bouge dans la commune c'est
le choix de cette association estime que
les inuits une belle commune il faut pas
qu'elle bouge il faut pas qu'à l'accueil
des nouvelles de temps si la loi est
respectée à la lettre la commune risque
une amende de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'euros
mais le système des sanctions n'est pas
toujours appliquée et près de 300
communes préfère de toute façon payer en
bref à propos d'économies le
gouvernement annonce une nouvelle mesure
d'urgence pour les routiers baisse de la
taxe à l'essieu est remise sur les
péages des autoroutes les organisations
patronales se réunissent demain pour
faire connaître leurs sentiments et
envisage éventuellement de nouvelles
actions comme celles menées ici en début
de semaine en attendant ce sont les
taxis qui ont encore manifesté
aujourd'hui rassemblement à toulouse
devant la préfecture de région et sur la
rocade ou encore ici à châlons en
champagne a toujours pour protester
contre les la hausse des prix du gazole
à l'étranger trois morts et une
quarantaine de blessés c'est le bilan
d'un attentat d'un nouveau genre à
jérusalem à palestiniens au volant d'une
pelleteuse a foncé dans la foule lui
même a ensuite été tué charles enderlin
sur place
cet autobus vient d'être renversé par la
pelleteuse un peu plus loin des voitures
qui ont été écrasés subitement la
pelleteuse qui s'était arrêté repas à
l'intérieur de la cabine à policiers
tentent de neutraliser le terroriste on
va
deux hommes finissent par ouvrir le feu
et tué le palestinien
les secours arrivent très vite il ya des
dizaines de blessés et des morts qu'il
faut dégager ce bébé de cinq mois a été
jeté par sa mère hors de la voiture
avant qu'elle soit écrasé par la
pelleteuse
la mère est morte l'auteur de cet
attentat habitait ce faubourg arabes de
jérusalem est
à 31 ans marié père de deux enfants il
était employé par la société qui réalise
le nouveau tramway de jérusalem
les enquêteurs cherchent à déterminer
s'il a agi seul ou s'il appartenait une
organisation palestinienne et le bilan
aurait pu être beaucoup plus lourd
bonsoir charles enderlin l'attentât a eu
lieu sous les fenêtres du bureau de
france 2 qu abrite aussi d'autres
chaînes de télévision oui tout à fait et
si le palestinien avec la pelleteuse
avait réussi à poursuivre son chemin
encore 100 ou 200 mètres vers le grand
marché juifs de marins et yebda qui se
trouve un peu plus loin il y aurait put
un véritable carnage cela dit
effectivement par hasard cela s'est
déroulé sous nos fenêtres et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous on a eu très
vite des images de ce drame
et puis aucun employé du bureau par
hasard aucun journaliste n'a été touché
alors que nous passons régulièrement sur
cette artère très importante de
jérusalem
merci charles en bref un mot de la
situation au zimbabwe le chef de
l'opposition morgan tsvangiraï rejette
l'idée d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale en inde un conflit
emblématique qui illustre le grand écart
d'un pays entre tradition et démocratie
dans une petite ville du sud un mur
sépare la population
d'un côté les castes supérieures de
l'autre les intouchables considéré comme
impur
malgré tous les recours la séparation
est toujours là envoyés spéciaux arnauld
miguet fabrice ionel dans ce village du
tamil nadu au sud de l'inde
il y à un mur entre les hommes ce mur il
fait trois mètres de haut et il court
sur 600 m de l'autre côté ce sont les
hautes castes un mur pour séparer les
communautés les purs d'un côté c'est à
dire les castes supérieures et les
impurs de l'autre les dalit c'est à dire
les opprimés les intouchables
ce sont les parias de la société mal née
ils resteront cantonnés aux tâches les
plus basses de père en fils sans espoir
d'en sortir
nous les dalit doute à pour amena vont
jamais reçu aucune aide de qui que ce
soit gouvernement partis politiques ou
angie on doit se débrouiller tout seul
pour s'en sortir en mai dernier les
parias en leur revanche sur ces images
amateurs on les voit en train de
détruire une partie de ce mur de la
honte
sous le regard médusé et impuissant des
autorités du coup aujourd'hui la police
est présente en permanence
et lorsque l'on essaie de passer de
l'autre côté avec une caméra chez les
castes supérieures personne ne veut
répondre à nos questions
un mur du silence
et c'est finalement la police qui nous
renvoie de l'autre côté vous avez rien à
faire dans ce coin du village en inde et
surtout dans les villages le fléau des
castes persiste avec ses nombreux codes
ces intouchables n'ont pas le droit par
exemple de boire avec les autres ils ont
donc leur propre café
cette ségrégation est valable aussi dans
les écoles où les enfants sont
stigmatisés dès leur plus jeune âge
selvarajah n'est ni la mégane tiennent à
nous montrer leur lieu de crémation les
loin de tout à l'écart pour éviter de
polluer l'air des autres diato la
discrimination de siva de la naissance à
la mort il n'y a pas d'ombré pas points
d'eau pas d'électricité
ici on ne fait des démarches à tous les
niveaux mais on n'a jamais obtenu quoi
que ce soit
en théorie le système de castes fut
abolie en 1948
mais cette mesure est largement resté
lettre morte dans la religion hindoue et
la société indienne sont attaché à ses
traditions ancestrales
il ya bien des exceptions qui confirment
la règle comme cet ancien président de
la république intouchable mais des murs
visibles ou invisibles amado rail comme
dans le reste de l'inde
il y en a encore des milliers la chine
rattrapé par la pollution à presque un
mois des jeux olympiques depuis une
semaine le site des compétitions de
voile à 500 km au sud de pékin est
envahie par des tonnes et des tonnes
d'algues vertes
leur prolifération est directement lié
semble-t-il rejets urbains c'est devenu
là bas une affaire nationale
dorothée cochard
on appelle cette mer la mer jaune et le
moins qu'on puisse dire depuis vendredi
c'est qu'elle porte mal son nom des
algues vertes proliférant obstruent le
port de qingdao censé accueillir dans un
mois les épreuves de voile des jeux
olympiques
les participants tout juste arrivé en
chine sont obligés de faire nettoyer
leur coque vous ne pouvez pas échapper à
ses rails ça vous en cercle et c'est
impossible de mener votre course à bien
donc si on parle franchement c'est
vraiment un gros problème
l'origine de cette invasion c'est la
pollution ces algues prolifèrent dans
les eaux usées saturé de détergents ou
d'engrais mais on ignore encore
l'origine exacte du phénomène mauvaise
publicité pour les chinois qui avait
pourtant promis que cjo seraient les
plus propres de l'histoire ce qui
n'ébranle en rien l'optimisme des
discours officiels
nous avons bon espoir si nous sommes
même confiant dans mon ombre devrions
pouvoir nettoyer la surface nécessaire à
la compétition d'ici le 15 juillet par
dizaines de milliers d anonymes avec
courage mais sans grands équipements
s'attaque aux gros nettoyage une course
contre le temps
les premières épreuves doivent commencer
le 9 août
on revient maintenant sur le fichier
edvige dont on parlait en début de
journal et qui permettra de recenser les
adolescents à partir de 13 ans je vous
le disais les oppositions sont vives pas
seulement sur les modalités mais sur le
principe même ce fichier est il utile
yat-il risques de dérives
voici les arguments des uns et des
autres edwige le débat avec aurélia
guillemin et sylvain gauthier
afin de 13 ou 14 ans et déjà des comptes
à rendre à la police
la scène est devenue banale dans
certains commissariats en france un acte
de délinquance sur cinq est commis par
un mineur mais le fichage des 13 ans est
il vraiment utile
la loi dit depuis trois siècles qu'on
entend dans un fichier de police ou dans
un fichier judiciaire en fonction de ce
qu'on fait pas de qui on est 13 ans et
l'âge de responsabilité pénale en france
mais un mineur de 10 ans qui commettra
un crime sur son petit frère entrerait
dans un fichier
quand un enfant à 13 ans et mis dans un
système délinquance hier dans un système
carcéral pénale on sait très bien qu'à
13 ans créé quelque chose qui est
irréversible qui est totalement
destructeur pour lui il est marginalisé
les délinquants ce sont encore des
enfants
les fichiers six jeunes fait donc
polémique
la commission nationale informatique et
libertés émet des réserves et les
défenseurs des droits de l'homme
dénoncent une dérive
aujourd'hui c'est fait simplement pour
déléguer encore une fois un tout petit
peu nos libertés individuelles
mais ce qui est grave ce qui est très
grave c'est que cette fois ci sur
l'autel des libertés individuelles
nous sacrifions nos enfants il est
naturel que la cnil émettre des idées
comme la ligue des droits de l'homme ou
d'autres organisations de défense des
libertés
il est aussi naturel de se rappeler
qu'ils ne défendent pas que des auteurs
mais aussi des victimes
tous deux s'accordent en tout cas sur un
point tout fichier est un nature
dangereuses et laissé site des garde
fous suffisants pour éviter les
agressions la politique le conseil
national du parti socialiste s'est
ouvert ce soir 21h contributions sont
déposées en vue du congrès de novembre
prochain
au delà des querelles de personnes dont
on parle très souvent nous avons voulu
ce soir évoqué les idées quelles
différences quelles orientations quel
débat qu'elle vit un bear alexis ans on
ramasse les copies ce soir au parti
socialiste
excepté laurent fabius et ségolène royal
tout le gratin est là et tout le monde
est censé avoir beaucoup travaillé ces
dernières semaines pour rédiger sa
contribution
ce soir on joue en soliste chacun défend
la priorité de son texte
je pense évidemment d'abord aux
priorités liées au pouvoir d'achat au
logement et je crée des propositions
extrêmement précis mais si gens
retenaient qu'une je retiendrai l'école
l'éducation un nouveau contrat social
dans le cadre de l'innovation de
l'investissement sur l'économie de
l'intelligence et la formation des
salariés
le mot clé si on veut gagner en 2012
c'est de la cohérence
c'est ce qui manque aujourd'hui au
sommet de l'état c'est ce qui a manqué
longtemps à la gauche
concrètement les chefs de file sont
d'accord sur bien des points par exemple
la fusion de l'impôt sur le revenu et la
csg
l'ensemble étant prélevé à la source
bertrand delanoë ségolène royal font la
même proposition
martine aubry suggère une allocation
d'autonomie pour les jeunes
en contrepartie ceci devrait donner du
temps pour des tâches d'intérêt général
la question des alliances divise
ségolène royal se prononce pour un
partenariat avec les centristes
pas question répondent tous les autres
notamment martine aubry bertrand delanoë
et laurent fabius
pour en finir avec les élections perdues
de nouveaux duos dans le ps se sont
créés
moi
nature a proposé au parti socialiste un
chemin pour gagner en 2011 et dans ce
chemin on trouve la 6ème république
défendue à la fois par ségolène royal
pierre moscovici ou benoît hamon l'ailé
gauche du ps
enfin ils sont tous d'accord pour
supprimer le paquet fiscal instauré un
chèque transport et accorder le droit de
vote aux étrangers aux élections locales
derrière la bataille des textes une
vingtaine de contributions au total le
grand enjeu est celui de la prise de
pouvoir
les prochaines semaines seront celles
des alliances pendant que le ps se
cherche une ligne et un chef
évidemment il a moins de temps pour
s'opposer toujours à propos de politique
on vient d'en voir beaucoup la cravate
va-t-elle être supprimés pendant l'été à
l'assemblée nationale ce n'est pas une
plaisanterie mais une proposition très
sérieuse d'un député verts il souhaite
ainsi réduire la facture de la
climatisation du palais bourbon et
lutter contre l'effet de serre thierry
curtet mathias secondes un député de
gauche
un ministre de droite un huissier hôtes
un point commun dans l'hémicycle la
cravate
pourtant rien dans le règlement ne
l'imposent françois de rugy l'a vérifié
à plus de 160 articles
il n'y a pas d'article sur le code
vestimentaire sur l'obligation
vestimentaire du costume et de la
cravate mais celle usage du coup elle
est devenue eaux plus calmes toi
alors on en jeu ce député communiste en
bleu de travail a pu pénétrer
l'hémicycle car il était en cravate et
je n'ai pourtant pas le symbole que ce
jeune député écologiste attaques non il
estime juste que la cravate en été ça
tient trop chaud c'est là qu'est ce que
vous n'avez pas de cravate qui est fait
pour autant voici bail que même les
médecins le disent souffre plus de la
chaleur qui vont du coup il faut pousser
la climatisation et donc brûler de
l'énergie un très mauvais exemple donné
par la représentation nationale qui
d'ailleurs n'est pas très développement
durable de l'assemblée nationale chauffe
beaucoup hiver climatisant n'était
utilisé des grosses limousines à une des
grosses cylindrées on parle du bonus
malus pour les voitures je conviens que
toutes les voitures de l'assemblée en le
malus et en plus de ça on ne trie pas
nos déchets alors qu'on croule sous des
montagnes de papier
votre travail est égale donc économies
d'énergie mais ce ne sera donc qu'un
début car dans ce décor où tout est
ritualisée les traditions ont la vie
dure
ce n'est qu'en 1981 que le président de
l'assemblée s'est défait de sa veste
on que depuis la même année les femmes
députées obtenait le port du pantalon
dans l'hémicycle françois de rugy lui se
plie encore aux obligations de temps en
temps il lève les yeux au plafond et on
vit les anges en tenue estivale toute
l'année en bref on se souvient de ces
terribles images du 30 septembre 2000 et
de cette fusillade dans la bande de gaza
entre soldats israéliens et palestiniens
un petit garçon de 12 ans mohamed al
doura avait été tué et son père
grièvement blessé et bien aujourd'hui le
président du crif le conseil
représentatif des institutions juives de
france demandent la création d'une
commission denquête pour analyser ces
images une demande qui fait écho aux
accusations selon lesquelles france 2
aurait mise en scène la séquence
certains prétendent même que le père et
l'enfant ne serait ni mort ni blessé
la direction de france 2 rappelle
qu'elle poursuivra toute personne qui
l'accusera de manipulation aucune preuve
de ses accusations n'ayant jamais été
apportée la santé ce que faire contre la
dyslexie
à l'heure où l'école ferme ses portes
tous les parents d'élèves concernés
savent à quel point ce trouble de la
lecture et de l'écriture pénalise les
enfants dans leur apprentissage
un élève sur dix seraient concernés
voici
une initiative originale et unique en
son genre le dépistage du risque de
dyslexie dès le cours préparatoire
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé josé blanc la pierre et david
fossard dans cette école on fait la
chasse aux difficultés scolaires pour
qu'apprendre ne soit plus une souffrance
parole d'ancien dyslexiques
c'était absolument atroce c'est à dire
une impression de maltraitance de
travailler dix fois plus que les autres
pour très peu de résultats et d'avoir en
permanence les gens qui disent fais
attention tu travailles tu es feignante
amatrices
moi je rêve au loup qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs dans la classe de fin de cp
tous les élèves savent lire
enfin presque tous un oui à mener un
cauchemar pour delphine un peu comme si
les portes de la lecture lui été fermé
sur lire tu aimerais lire pour retrouver
la sueur enseignants s'interrogent
difficile de trouver l'origine du
blocage de delphine une petite fille a
priori comme les autres c'est sûr que
tout est rasé y est qu un très bon
contact avec les autres qui
j'aime bien comme il faut qui fait du
sport qui est très à l'aise avec elle
même mais peut-être un problème pour m
dessus de concentrer son énergie à un
moment donné sur l'apprentissage à la
lecture alors aujourd'hui c'est son tour
delphine quitte la classe avec
l'orthophoniste chargé du dépistage de
tous les cp 1h30 de test pour essayer de
comprendre pourquoi delphine n'accroche
pas et ainsi lui trouver une aide
extérieure adapté touche
donc ça permet de de prévenir les
parents s'ils ne sont pas déjà parce
qu'en fin d'année un enfant qui est
quand même je pense qu'il ya déjà eu des
alertes fait par l'enseignant mais de
dire il est temps de consulter ça ne
s'est pas débloqués mais pour autant on
va pas dire que c'est une dyslexie parce
que c'est trop tôt un corbeau perchée
sur l'antenne d'un bâtiment car la sexy
peut aller jusque là des inversions un
phrasé mal découpé à ce stade pour un
élève on parle de handicap scolaire
jules ii - de faire indique t il à
toujours zéro le pauvre il a toujours 06
doit prendre des notes et bien après il
peut plus revenir
donc il va avoir un message distordue
apprendre ce qui fait que c'est pourquoi
vous recommande souvent que ces enfants
bénéficient d' aide par exemple leur
donne des polycopiés ou qu'on leur
permettent d'apprendre leur leçon par la
voie orale c'est à dire en enregistrant
les leçons 10 % des enfants sont
concernés par la dyslexie un trouble
neurologique dans le diagnostic se
confirme en c1 mais plus vite ce
dysfonctionnement est débusqué plus vite
il peut être rééduqués voilà qui nous
amène aux congés scolaires avec un
chiffre qui retient l'attention regarder
d'après une enquête de la jeunesse
ouvrière chrétienne 40 % des jeunes de
15 à 30 ans ne partent pas en vacances
chaque année 17 % ne partent presque
jamais exemple a grenoble c'est étonnant
mais c'est la vérité certains jeunes des
quartiers sensibles n'ont jamais vu les
montagnes de près alors qu'ils habitent
au pied des sommets depuis cinq ans la
mairie a décidé de les prendre en charge
denis sébastien eric chacun sur place
avec à la main droite et captant du ils
partent à la conquête d'un rêve
l'ascension d'un sommet de plus de 4000
mètres d'altitude leurs yeux sont encore
embués de sommeil ils se sont levés à 3
heures du matin une heure à laquelle
certains d'entre eux parfois se couche
la progression sur le glacier est longue
avant de rentrer dans le vif du sujet
bon là ça rapport ollier quoi la plaine
parce qu'ils ont marchons marchons
marchons voit pas le bout mais bon là on
va attaquer la partie la plus
intéressante donc ça va aligner deux
filles 10 garçons âgés de 13 à 17 ans
point commun il vivait à grenoble
entourée de montagnes que jusqu alors
il ne fréquentait pas petit à petit on
leur a donc fait prendre de l'altitude
des randonnées d'abord quelques sommets
plus modestes et aujourd'hui cette
ascension qui couronnent leurs efforts
visage est assez grand favori lacroix se
trouve en elle et profonde nuit ça fait
ça impressionne les jeunes sont encadrés
par des guides de haute montagne est
accompagné par l'éducateur qui les suit
toute l'année dans leur quartier
lentement mais sûrement les cordes et
progresse et bientôt l'objectif est en
vue allez nous resterons te m est revenu
au sommet votre premier 4000 enfin
c'était un peu dur mais m'est arrivé on
est tous content je crois je suis fier
mais mes jeux faciles et enfin quand on
veut impose un fait ça c'est valable
pour toute la vie il serait c'est
fabuleux de voir qu'ils sont tous montés
au dôme des écrins et que certains
d'entre eux ne connaissaient pas la
banque
une journée qui aura peut-être fait
naître des vocations chez certains
en tous les cas pour tous un souvenir
inoubliable
et à propos de vacances gare aux orages
météo france émet un bulletin d' alerte
de vigilance orange jusqu'à demain 6h 21
départements sont concernés vous le
voyez sur l'est du pays
soyez prudent si vous devez vous
déplacer je vous rappelle l'une des
informations que nous vous donnions en
début de journal deux étudiants français
à londres ont été tués dimanche à leur
domicile deux étudiants originaires de
clermont ferrand nous venons de joindre
bertand cochery consul général de france
à londres
je vous propose d'écouter son témoignage
il y a les corps de deux jeunes français
qui ont été retrouvés dans une maison où
il y avait eu un incendie toutes les
dispositions nécessaires ont été prises
pour organiser le plus rapidement
possible la venue des de leur famille à
londres la police britannique a assuré
les familles j'en ai été témoin puisque
j'étais à leurs côtés aujourd'hui les a
assurées de leur queue de mobilisation
dans la recherche des auteurs du meurtre
voilà pour cette toute première
précision donc sur ce double meurtre
qu'on a appris ce soir la saison des
festivals direction montpellier pour la
danse et jusqu'au 5 juillet une
quinzaine de créations avec des
compagnies du monde entier l'occasion de
découvrir les plus grands chorégraphes
et aussi les talents de demain abdelah
mostefa frédéric capron sur une place à
l'extérieur de montpellier une troupe
venue du burkina faso avec ses danses de
transe pendant ce temps là dans une
salle dédiée à l'opéra juste le son des
cors pour un ballet sans la moindre note
des danseurs traditionnels délaissant
leur show demain un seul temps d'un
festival des danseurs professionnels
abandonnant leurs repères musicaux
habituel c'est le festival montpellier
danse qui fait le grand écart comme
toujours il faut montrer la danse en
tout c est axée sur la recherche que
soient les grandes compagnies
néoclassique américaines que sont les
compagnies de flamenco espagnol ou des
compagnies françaises montrer tout où tu
mets ta de toute la danse certains
journaux disent que montpellier danse
est une photographie de la danse au
moment je suis à la lieu dans le nouveau
paysage de la danse
il faudra compter avec emmanuel gat
chorégraphe israélien installé depuis
peu en france
emmanuel gat chorégraphe au parcours
atypique
venu à la danse sur le tard un peu par
hasard ou pas je sais pas je vous allez
gérer 23 ans va femme qui m'a amené un
jour devant chez eux on y à un atelier
des transformateurs suis à l'aise pu
rester capable d'imaginer des spectacles
sur du jean sébastien bach ou de la
musique électro emmanuel gat ne
s'interdit rien
à l'image de montpellier dans ce
festival où l'on pourra voir d'ici à
samedi soir des moines shaolin ou encore
un duo de danseurs interdits aux moins
de 18 ans une image à la rubrique people
l'actrice américaine angelina jolie a
été admise dimanche soit à la maternité
qu'il accueillera jusqu'à la fin de sa
grossesse
à nice elle nous a révélé il ya quelques
semaines qu'elle attendait des jumeaux
et c'est brad pitt qu'on découvre son
époux qui l'a rejoint dans cette chambre
avec vue imprenable paraît-il sur la mer
et la promenade des anglais
un mot du tennis à wimbledon
on attend peut-être ce soir mais sans
doute demain raison d'une interruption
de la pluie
arnaud clément pour son quart de finale
en attendant vous le voyez c'est rodger
federer qui s'est qualifiée assez
facilement face à honnechy tx pour les
demi finales et puis un autre football
aussi avec le transfert confirmé d'hatem
ben arfa le milieu offensif de lyon
rejoint l'olympique de marseille les
deux clubs sont parvenus à un accord
financier
hier soir transfert de 12 millions
d'euros plus un bonus d'un million en
cas de qualification de l'om en ligue
des champions après le tour préliminaire
avant de refermer ce journal je vous
rappelle l'une des principales
informations que nous avons développées
à patrick de carolis sort de sa réserve
pour la première fois le président de
france télévisions marc publiquement son
désaccord avec la réforme en cours
annoncé par nicolas sarkozy
il n'exclut pas de démissionner c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi tout de suite la météo tania young
attention donc aux orages 20h50 la suite
et la fin de votre saga le sanglot des
anges à demain
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr